[Music]
[Music]
in 2048
a huge earthquake claimed the lives of
hundreds of thousands of people
climate change has ravaged earth with
increased seismic activity over the last
hundred years
scientists had discovered that the
earthquakes were only going to get worse
and worse eventually they would get to
the point of shaking the world
so much that cities would crumble and
oceans would boil
leaving earth uninhabitable
earth was fast approaching its use by
date
officials began experimenting with a
number of ideas to ensure the survival
of the species
some plans included floating cities or
digging deep underground
others included looking beyond earth in
search of planets within the goldilocks
zone
which is neither too hot nor too cold to
sustain human life
following through with this plan two
enormous ships the caravel
and the flores were crafted in orbit
their goal was to find a new planet
where humanity could call home
probes were sent ahead of the ships to
find the perfect spot for them to land
the outriders group was established to
be the first people to set foot on an
alien planet
they were supposed to be the best of
humanity in such a situation
there were mercenaries survivors and
explorers
their mission was to secure a perimeter
and prepare for the landing
of the colony ship
the probes that were sent out eventually
returned promising results
a planet named enoch appears to be able
to provide
an experience similar to earth
acceptable temperatures
breathable atmosphere and gravitational
pull perfect for human life
but before it can be confirmed as
humanity's new home the outriders need
to be sent in
so in the year 2159 the future of the
human species
is loaded onto two colony ships and sets
forth on an 80-year journey through
space
towards the planet enoch the majority of
whom would be in cairo sleep
however it didn't start out smoothly the
caravel was destroyed before it could
leave orbit
most of the people on board were killed
teams had to quickly scramble together
to rebuild units of outriders
based on who was left a large amount of
whom were mercenaries and freelancers
with no ties to any sorts of authority
unit
from its orbit enoch appears to be
everything that the scientists said it
would be
although at this point after traveling
for 82 years contact with earth
had been lost 15 years ago so regardless
of how they felt
enoch was now their only option
leaving the colony ship along with the
500 000 civilians on board
the outriders take landing pods down to
the planet
enoch is not a complete replica of earth
there are certainly some unusual
alien qualities to it but there are
definite features that could be related
like the trees and even some odd
mammal-type creatures running around
a base camp has been set up and trucks
and military are buzzing around
working on the settlement the military
is there to watch over the outriders
being a rag-tag group of freelancers and
mercenaries the military doesn't trust
them
the plan is to start thawing out
civilians and sending them planetside
a few thousand at a time this would
allow a slow and steady transition
to test how the infrastructure handles
the increased workload over time
while working on the first city it's up
to the outriders to further explore and
expand on their new home
the probe that landed on the planet was
giving off some unusual signals
so the first stop for the outriders and
a unit of military guard
was to push forward and find its
location
but suddenly there is a huge blast
all vehicles and equipment stop working
it begins raining and that's when it
starts
everything around them begins to
transform rocks start floating
local wildlife turned into hulking
aggressive beasts
and there is now this low-pitched
rumbling sound
they make it to the probe though the
signal was coming from there it wasn't
the thing producing
it it was simply relaying and amplifying
another signal coming from somewhere
else on the planet
things continue to get worse trees start
falling around them
the rumbling sound is quickly getting
replaced by explosions and screaming
the outriders that were able to survive
the anomaly were forced to retreat back
where they entered a state of
chirostasis
thirty years later the outriders
awakened to a new enoch
while humanity has in fact managed to
colonize the planet
it is now plagued by monstrous creatures
and other dangerous wildlife and plant
life
that frequently kill the little progress
that the survivors can make
the anomaly has crippled technology and
created an environment where inhabitants
have been forced to dig themselves into
a valley
enormous storms cover the surface of a
knock they are brutal
and make most of the planet
uninhabitable
the survivors of the anomaly have split
off into various factions
civil war has broken out between what's
left of surviving humans
some of which have been completely
corrupted by the anomaly leaving little
trace of humanity in their system
while in their chiropods the outriders
too have evolved
they awake finding themselves with
mysterious new abilities
and then there is the strange signal
that started it all
it's still active no one has been able
to get out of the valley to investigate
what it is
and there was only one outrider who made
a note of the frequency before entering
the 30-year sleep
it's up to this individual to
investigate the signal that could be
located anywhere on the planet
and through doing this they may find a
place beyond the anomaly
where humanity can give this another
shot an attempt to begin
once again
as a cooperative multiplayer shooter
it's a fun mix between a third person
shooter
and an action rpg with up to a team of
three players can run around different
locations on the planet
and battle with hostiles including
vicious creatures and super-powered
bosses
other than gunplay players are able to
utilize class-based abilities
and synchronize them along with your
teammates while still building towards a
unique style of play
outriders is looking like a game that
will contain a vast and satisfying
narrative
i'm actually looking quite forward to
trying this out and fingers crossed
being that it's a 2021 release the
difficulties that have plagued the
releases of more recent games hopefully
won't be showing face anytime soon
i hope you've enjoyed this video and
i'll catch you in the next one cheers
you